grève illimitée pour les salariés de
sanofi chimie c'est devant les grilles
du site de saint-aubin-lès-elbeuf en
seine-maritime qu'une centaine d'entre
eux se sont réunis mardi en cause un
projet d'externalisation de leur usine à
la fin du mois d'octobre en fait on sera
dans une filiale de sanofi puis ensuite
introduit en bourse sanofi se
désengagera de nous séparer de nos
usines et nous luttons pour partir en
fait quelque part dans les meilleures
conditions et surtout avoir des
garanties sur la pérennité de notre
usine préparer nos emplois et qu'on les
visions à long terme ce que nous n'avons
absolument pas leur accueil la filiale
en question se nomme euros à pays elle
est spécialisée dans la production de
principes actifs pharmaceutiques
surfant sur la vague de carence en
production locale qui a frappé l'europe
au début de la pandémie de kovy 19
grands jeux productions majeures de la
vitamine b12 compléments alimentaires et
de l'apprécier un missile la prise d'un
missile est un produit très important
vous le trouverez sûrement commercial à
la pioche fascine c'est un antibiotique
qui est qui traite les manettes par les
infections pulmonaires et c'est un
antibiotique de la dernière chance c'est
à dire que c'est un gentil petit connais
très peu de résistance pour qui connaît
un qui rencontré peu de résistance et
qui soignent très efficacement sanofi
choisi le profit le groupe a pourtant
dégagé 13 milliards d'euros de bénéfices
sur l'exercice 2020 alors que la
pandémie battait son plein une situation
qui met en colère les salariés
concrètement les produits qu'ils ne
rapportent moins d'argent
sanofi 200 m -t respect dont ils
essaient de les sortir du groupe pourra
investir dans les biotechnologies les
vaccins la rn message et c'est l'avenir
de sanofi pour nous ce qu'on demande
c'est de l'investissement de la part de
sanofi doit me sortir dans de bonnes
conditions il ya des projets qui
arrivent sur les sites mais à la basse
et c'était des projets sanofi donc ils
doivent nous donner des installations en
bon état pour pouvoir les fabriquer la
grève a démarré le 6 septembre et doit
continuer jusqu'à ce que les salariés
obtiennent des réponses concrètes sur
l'avenir de leur usine une session en 3
jalons au 1er octobre l'usiné change de
nom en mars 2022 elle entrera en bourse
à la fin de ce processus sanofi ne
gardera que 30% des effectifs de la
société rendant defacto euro un pays
quasiment indépendant et de laissant que
peu de marge de négociation aux salariés
restants en europe très autre usine de
sanofi sont concernés par le projet et
c'est le même sort que le laboratoire
pharmaceutique semble réservée à ses
salariés en tout ils seraient près de
3000 être concernées dont milan france